Saying the word of God is not absolute or sovereign. You already have an agenda.
You're trying to fit the Bible into that agenda. Without the gospel,
people are going to help. And that's a very serious issue,
more serious than sexual orientation or a boarded baby.
[Inaudible].
It says in Romans that if you confess with the mouth and believe in the heart,
that Jesus is Lord, then you will surely be saved, praying, reading your Bible.
I think following the commandments is a minimum.
Someone who tries to reflect God's love in their life.
Welcoming people to love each other and be compassionate.
And listen is essentially what Jesus asked us to do.
When we're approaching different topics like homosexuality,
or like pro-choice pro-life.
We have to go into them thinking about what the Bible says.
I would prefer to have the world or society or culture or their peers dictate
their life. There are rules that are associated with being progressive.
The problem comes in when people try to create unnecessary
boundaries.
[inaudible].
I'm angel. I'm a worship leader and I'm excited to be here. I am Jason.
I'm the YouTuber known as pastor Jason answers. I'm happy to be here.
I'm Siara um, I do hair and I work with children.
Hi, I'm Olivia. I'm a college student.
Hello. My name is Kurt. I am a senior pastor. I am Brenda.
I am the YouTuber known as God is gray.
And I'm so excited to have a civilized conversation with you all
step forward. If you agree with the statement,
the Republican party embodies Christian values more
than the democratic party.
I don't know a whole bunch about politics,
but when I see like pro-life things like that,
I would have to just deduce from that, that Republican is more Christ centered,
right? I'm not talking about big government versus small government regulation.
I'll talk about specifically, pro-life talking about education,
public education of transgender. I'm talking about marriage.
I grew up in a very conservative far right church.
I used to be a Trump supporter, although I wasn't even,
I'm not even a us citizen,
but one thing that really hurt me and changed my perspective was
how they talk about immigration and poor people like
myself.
I grew up in poverty and planned Parenthood is my PCP because
they take Medicaid.
But when I found out that my friends actually, um,
the silent protest in front of planned Parenthood,
that really changed my perspective a lot,
like over 75% of people who get abortion are low
income. I like you have been in not poverty,
but in situations where I couldn't afford health insurance,
universal health care is the most Christ-like thing I can imagine.
It's it's full of compassion. It's saying, yeah,
maybe you have to take this out of my pocket,
but it's for the poor who can't afford it. I'm like that's Jesus to me.
I don't see what's going on there.
In regards to abortion specifically.
I do think that that is someone's future in there.
And I think that the choice between if that future has played out or not as
gods,
and I take that from Psalms where it says that his eyes saw our substance being
yet informed and he fashioned our days when yet there were none of them.
And so the moment at conception, when that baby exists,
no matter how small they are, their whole future is lined up.
And I know that sometimes circumstances on how those babies come about suck and
I've met someone that was a product of that, okay?
Their biological father raped their mother and she doesn't know who her
biological father is, but I just couldn't, I couldn't imagine life without her.
What about the mother that finds out that she's pregnant and she goes to the
hospital and they tell her that it's a high risk pregnancy.
And that if she does take the baby to term that she runs the risk
of, of giving birth and actually dying.
I think that in those circumstances, in those situations,
I think that they should trust.
The Lord. So what if the Lord tells him to have an abortion?
I'm just going to have to say, trust the Lord. And I'm not a woman.
I will never be put in that place. So.
I asked that because I have a, I have a friend that his daughter,
um, went through that and he chose his daughter over the
baby.
And so they ended up having an abortion and he was pro-life prior to
that circumstance.
I would still trust God. I think if I was in that situation,
I would pray with my husband and call on my church and my family let's
come together and pray about this. And whatever God like God's will,
will be done. If my life be taken,
then I pray that this baby will be used and that he would give me the comfort
and the peace to get through that situation.
LGBTQ plus couples should be allowed to get married in the
church
Personally. I think they should be able to,
because they can have a marriage that glorifies God,
just like any straight couples can. Well, I do believe that homosexuality.
Is a sin. I can't tell you what you can can or can't do with your life.
And I do think that you should have the same rights that I have in the same way
that I have the right to believe differently.
I have to also extend that right to you.
Well, I'm married to a wonderful man. And so, um,
so of course I would have to agree with the LGBTQ, um,
be allowed to get married in the church.
When I was deep in evangelicalism, the narrative was being gay as a sin.
And then I saw the church sort of like soften up or change the narrative to
okay, being gay. Isn't a sin. God made you gay,
but you can never act on homosexuality. That's the sin in the act. But again,
I don't see the harm.
I see beautiful couples like this gentleman here.
So when we look at suicidal ideation,
we look at trans women being murdered because of the bigotry in this nation,
a lot propagated by Christians, evangelicals,
conservatives, the fruit of that doctrine.
We've been planting for not only decades, but centuries.
First, what LGBTQ people do with their lives is none of my business.
And I believe they should have the same rights as other couples do in terms of
government assistance, uh, freedoms of tax benefits, of course,
that there should be no discrimination,
but when they come to the church and they're saying,
can you approve our marriage before God?
I can't disregard what I believe the Bible says and say, Oh,
forget what the Bible says. So that could be more accepting of people.
I respect totally as individuals as
Americans. I think you have rights. However,
I have to go based off of the Bible and the Bible equates homosexuality to
sexual immorality. And so I care about you guys, as,
as people that that's not gonna, that's not gonna make me justify.
I know that you mentioned like murders and suicide rates. I,
I don't agree with any of that. And I think that's terrible.
But why do you think those are happening?
You can no longer say I that's horrible.
What's happening over there because this theology is the basis
of that suicidal ideation. In many cases, it is the basis of transphobia.
In many cases,
if you see all of this atrocious pain we're causing the LGBTQ plus community,
then we need to look at the plank in our own eye and say, wait,
why is this happening? There's a.
It mentions all of the people who won't enter the kingdom of heaven.
And I can talk about what Leviticus says about homosexuality or the people who
engage in that. But I just base off as Christians.
If our goal is to get to heaven. I know that if I'm a drunk,
I know if I'm a foreigner cater. I know if I'm an adulterer, if I'm homeless,
living a homosexual lifestyle, I will not enter the kingdom of heaven.
That's what the Bible says.
The word, homosexuality not even.
Entered into biblical texts until probably like the
1900.
And the original texts are Santa coy, Thai and mallow.
Koi are in our English rendition. It says homosexuality.
But those literally translate to pedophilia it's relationship between an older
man and his young son.
Verses that, say,
a man shall not sleep with another man for it is an abomination that
there's no word for homosexuality.
And Matt is just no dudes sleep with other dude.
I can see how you can see that relating to first Timothy passage.
But if you look at Romans chapter one, verse 26 and 27,
it's clearly in context is talking about quote, unquote unnatural relationship.
It doesn't say homosexual,
but it's talking about men having committing acts with them.
Yeah. Well, the problem with that is that.
So in Romans that's Paul writing, right?
And so Paul is writing. Yes, no, it was Paul writing.
[inaudible].
Letters to churches. God's saying it's not the same thing.
No, no, no. You didn't let me finish because
the text says natural affection. Well,
my natural affection is not towards a woman.
My natural affection is towards a man.
Are dividing things in the Bible and progressives want to get rid of that
because they want to focus on God loves you,
accepts you and puts his arms around you.
But in the process have also watered down the gospel also, uh,
deleted some things that they know what the Bible says,
and because we don't want to cast people away.
So I love that heart.
But I think in the process of watering down the gospel,
you've set the bar so low that do they even see the real guy?
You have to be very careful when we talk about the literalism of the Bible.
Because if we do that, then basically everyone in this room is saying,
because we have mixed tweets.
Do we know the context of Leviticus? Yes. I know the context of it.
Context and little bit, but not contact.
Well, no. What I'm saying is Leviticus.
The law that came was for the people of Israel when they were rescued from the
captivity of Egypt. But we see in Jeremiah 31 31,
that the Lord says that he will build a new covenant under the house of Judah
and under the house of Israel, which is still scripture.
So if we go based off of what we see in Exodus and Leviticus, that law has gone.
You're allowing for context in history, which you don't allow for.
That's not fair. I've gone through some sort of conversion therapy myself.
Although they called it counseling to serve as a leader or to
serve in different department.
And I always questioned why are divorced people
able to serve and do things?
And it's not really a big of a deal in most churches.
Whereas a lot of churches, they have a statement of faith that says, if you,
if you disagree with our, um, marriage,
or like the traditional marriage model, you can not serve.
I've never heard any pastor telling someone who's divorced to go back to
their ex-husband or ex-wife like, they say, it's the same level of sin,
but how come this people are like, okay, and this people are not.
So that's the problem. I see.
I'm not going to be a literal list here,
but please don't be offended because I do admire your courage in coming out.
But I believe homosexuals will not be in heaven.
I believe homosexuals transgenders people break the speed limit.
We'll all go to heaven.
If they put their faith in Jesus Christ as your personal Lord and savior. But,
but when they get to heaven, they will no longer be homosexuals.
There was no longer be law breakers.
They will no longer be drunks based on first Corinthians six first nine.
We can actually see what God's will is clearly based on what it is in heaven.
So when it comes to tendencies with homosexuality,
that's something that I've dealt with since I was very young. However,
I don't choose to identify with those tendencies that are within me.
I choose to identify with what the Bible declares that I am.
And are you miserable? No. No, not at all. You're not. No,
because the joy of the Lord is my strain.
Could I ask a, an invasive question? You can say now, are you bisexual?
No, there's a big possibility. I may never get married. Okay.
There's a big possibility. You may never get married because of what.
Because I choose to trust in the Lord and I choose to do as the scripture says
and believe as the scripture.
So do you have inclinations and desires to like,
to be with a guy.
Have desires and inclinations to follow the voice of the Lord?
And I, and I respect that. Like I honestly did.
That's a lot of self-control to say, basically you're down to the,
have a life of self.
I was kinda nervous that we'll talk about it a little bit,
but I feel like it's a topic that's a lot more in the dark when it comes to the
church. And I don't know,
I just feel like we need to move forward in a different approach than the way
we've been going, because it does break my heart,
seeing people committing suicide and,
and hearing about some of the violent conclusions that some people's lives have
gotten to.
I feel like if anybody has any reason to find like an
explanation for how I could get around scripture and marry a male,
it just, I just can't. I, I.
Okay.
Could I also just ask you where you received that message for the first time.
Some people in church that would say like, you know, that that was a choice.
And I realized that I had no control over what I like or what I
don't like, literally I don't. And I can agree with you with that.
I think the choice comes in is choosing to identify with those beliefs and
choosing to identify with tendencies.
Inside of you. That's where I believe it becomes.
For me. I try to suppress that. Um, for a years, I, you know,
um, I had a girlfriend, I, I,
I did all of these different things and it was like, Oh no, it's a sin.
It's that? But I had a relevatory moment when the
church was mean to me, put him over here.
We don't want them with anybody, kick him out, do that.
It wasn't no one showed me the authentic love of Christ.
But you know, who showed me the authentic level of Christ,
my friends who were gay,
I had to go to counseling because of what the church did to me.
And the counselor is the one who was not a Christian,
helped me to understand people in the church hurt you,
not God. And so, because God did not hurt me,
I could stand in a church and get married to a man because God did not hurt me.
I can stand up every Sunday and preach to transgender, straight people,
gay people.
I can do all of that because of the authenticity of who and what I
know God is.
Jesus.
Protest for the black lives matter movement.
Jesus cares so much about everyone that I think that
he, he may, we see him making stance stances,
um, especially in the synoptic gospels, you know, throughout texts.
We see him like actually standing up for people.
The gospel is not about black lives matter,
but Jesus often stood up for those who are oppressed for those who are
discarded. Those were marginalized.
I'm not saying everything about the black lives matter is perfect or good as if
any movement is, but he would stand up for those who are voiceless. Yeah.
I think Jesus.
Foot protest for the lives of one lost sheep.
My struggle with not stepping forward was really like,
we all have a different voice and a way that we can protest in a way that would
be best. Like I had a newborn child,
so I couldn't get out on the streets because of Corona. Like,
that's why I wasn't there. So anyone that wasn't there,
I wouldn't say was on the wrong side of history it's but it was like,
what are you doing to actively advocate in your life?
Or you're educating yourself about white supremacy?
Are you becoming actively anti-racist.
I wouldn't envision like Jesus out there with like a sign,
because I do believe that black lives matter.
I do believe that all lives matter,
but I don't think I need to protest in order for me
to.
Prove that you have to remember that this same Jesus whooped the hell out of a
temple because,
because they were in there doing things that, that they, um,
that they should not have been doing.
And we see him go in and be very vengeful in his approach of turning,
flipping over tables and doing different things to protest that
God's house was supposed to be a house of prayer and that they had made it into
a den of thieves.
I mean, I get it historically,
if this happened in the first century in something like a black lives matter was
happening,
I don't think Jesus would be part of that because that was not part of his
mission. That's not,
but today what Jesus want me to be part of it as he's living his life
through me, then I would answer yes. To stand up for those who are oppressing.
The other side, misrepresents Christianity.
I feel misrepresented in that. Um,
I often say that the evangelical or conservative church has built an idol to
sexual purity and sexual integrity,
which is why the gay issue is so high on the agenda.
And the pro-choice pro-life issue. The Bible is not a sex manual,
but so often I see it being presented as like the utmost issue
and what we're talking about earlier about social justice and all of these other
beautiful things that I believe Jesus would be a part of, you know,
Jesus himself was not harping on people's sexuality constantly.
I think a lot of people turn to the progressive side because they're hurt by the
church and what the church did to them and how the church treated them.
It's showing people come as you are and stay as you are instead of
come as you are and let God change you and let God work in you to
not live the way you were before,
but to change and have a new life and become a new creation
and join me in heaven.
Well, I feel misrepresented because like you said,
you think it's about the issues like sexuality or social justice.
I feel like because they want to accept it because they want people to know
about the love of God. They're misrepresenting the love of God.
And that's what conservatives care about the word of God and the gospel.
Again, I go back to like the inerrancy of scripture,
which I see a lot in conservative church.
I do not believe the words of Paul are the words of God.
And that's definitely where we veer off for a lot of people. That's a big thing.
Like we believe that just all scripture, including that,
which Paul wrote was inspired by God. And so, no,
I believe it's all inspired by God, but I don't believe it's literally God,
the only reason I'm going in on this is to clarify that we love and honor the
Bible too. We really do. I read my Bible every single day.
And I think that is the thing that most conservatives don't understand about.
Progressive's more than anything. Welcome.
Are ambiguities of like this and that. And our, this is the way you see it.
That's an age old thing. If you go back and you look,
that's why Martin Luther posted the 95 thesis on the
Catholic church,
because he had all of these issues or all of these problems with what they
thought religiously. And he goes on and to start the Lutheran church.
And then like, um, my sister said, we read the same Bible. We,
I get up. And I re I read that study my Bible every week.
Progressive Christianity is seeing the Christianity that we grew up in
and then seeing a problem and that we realize, okay, let's fix it.
So we come up with new ideas and new ways to fix it.
But based on the scripture that we all grew up reading.
When I, when I pastor my church and they're having a hard time understanding the
scriptures, I'm gentle with them because they're trying to learn.
But I feel like it'd be harsh with progressive Christians. Because if they,
if you claim to be a Christian, you should know better. And I believe,
especially after this talk, you don't know how to interpret the word.
You are dishonoring God, because you are not doing his will. Now.
I firmly believe that because saying the word of God is not absolute or
sovereign.
You're saying you're picking and choosing based on your interpretations.
I think your hermeneutics is off.
See that my church members are trying to learn.
It seems like you already have an agenda.
You're trying to fit the Bible into that agenda instead of accepting the gospel
for what it is that without the gospel, people are going to help.
And that's a very serious issue,
more serious than sexual orientation or aborted babies.
And I think that's the key issue between conservatives and progressors.
It's not a bathroom issues. It's about the word of God.
And when you disrespect the word of God, like you are doing it.
Like Mr. POWs.
Because your hermeneutics is wrong. Not necessarily.
Though. I probably wouldn't have said it as Kurt.
I do believe that the gospel is essential above topics of,
and though the church,
hasn't done a great job with capitalizing on some sins and not really talking
about the other, like I know that we mentioned divorce earlier. Um,
I do think the gospel is of primary importance. And I,
I would have to second that,
like my biggest thing is just like taking parts of scripture and then not taking
the other. Um, but.
I would probably missed this Curt, but yeah.
As an African-American, we dealt with slavery.
And if you go back and you study history and you look at the,
the history of black people, we were in doctrine,
NYSED by the Bible, slaves obey your masters.
And they indoctrinated that into us to, to keep us oppressed.
When you talk about literalism, when it comes to scripture,
you have to be very careful because if you, because if you do that,
then, then you open up something that is catastrophic.
I think it's terrible that people scripture out of context,
because all man was created in the likeness of God, all men,
all men, all people. So when they were quoting verses about slavery,
they disregarded what was said in Genesis.
In the beginning that all people were created in the likeness of God.
If all men were created in the image of God, then that's gay people.
That's transgender people. That's, um, African-American people,
that's Asian people. That's all you're talking about race,
sexual identity. Those are completely different. They're, they're idle.
Here's the energy I choose to walk outside and identify as being black
or not. I got black skin.
Whether I choose to identify with behaviors on how I feel is a completely
different thing. Well,
that's when you're going into a lifestyle and orientation and,
and that's an argument.
There is a danger. I agree in, in interpreting scripture,
literally because it can be so easily weaponized against people.
Interracial marriage was illegal in this country until 1967.
And there were Christian women protesting because white Christians thought it
was unbiblical. And it was in the Bible.
It was clear that we're not supposed to be mixing with other races.
I can't say you're going to hell. I can't say that.
Cause I don't know her relationship with God.
And I can't say the same for you or you.
And even between us as conservative Christians,
we identify a different belief systems.
I think just this world is not our home.
Our focus is on making it to heaven
and doing what we can to get there and making sure that we're reaching people
along the way,
the church does need to do a better job of reaching people in a
respectful, caring, loving way,
not just throwing scripture down someone's throat are not just throwing
standards or what they think is right.
But what Jesus showed us to live by loving our neighbor as ourselves and to
make connections with people and truly care about the person and the soul,
because this life is just temporary.